foreign
buildings are not only what they seem
they aren't Just Energy structures to
live and work in
they are connected to the energy system
and this makes buildings an essential
elements of the efforts to decarbonize
our world
today I want to talk about changing our
thinking around the role of buildings in
the Energy System
and how they can transform to bring us
closer to our climate targets
but first I want to take you to where I
grew up
in this building in a mid-sized city in
Russia
to me it looked just a gray concrete box
like many others
that I indeed numerous buildings like
this across Europe and Central Asia
inherited from Soviet times
they were built quickly to house as many
people as possible without much
consideration for their design comfort
and energy usage
this is true of many many buildings
across the world non-discreet housing
and Office boxes built fast and cheap
and all connected to the Energy System
I live in Paris now and all buildings
there look much nicer
from the perspective of energy issues
are similar
high energy consumption Reliance on
fossil fuels and high energy costs
driven even higher by the current energy
crisis
in Paris I work with International
Energy agency and we advise in
governments across the world on various
energy issues and for that
we look at data a lot
and our data shows that at the global
scale buildings are responsible for
about one-third of total energy
consumption and energy and process
related carbon dioxide emissions
in Europe for example 90 percent of
buildings that exist today will still be
standing and in use by 2050.
we're also building more new buildings
our data shows that the global floor
area is expected to increase by 75
percent by mid-century
this is equivalent to adding the area
size of Paris every week for the next 30
Years
if this happens with energy consumption
patterns of today
this alone will make it very difficult
to achieve our climate targets
fortunately we do have Solutions
available
to reduce direct emissions from
buildings by more than 95 percent by
2050. and for this we need three things
efficiency
electrification and decarbonization
Energy Efficiency must come first and in
buildings it should be improved in two
ways
first through improving Energy
Efficiency of the building envelope with
better materials design Solutions
insulation of walls roofs basements
energy efficient windows second through
improving Energy Efficiency of all
appliances and equipment used in
building for space heating and cooling
water heating lighting cooking working
and entertainment
however Energy Efficiency as they say
takes a village
many forces and interests interact
during construction and renovation of a
building
the developers the owners The Regulators
The Architects the suppliers of
Technologies the market itself exerting
price pressure
all these need to be aligned and it all
starts with the government's mandating
minimum Energy Efficiency requirements
through their regulation putting the
right incentives in place
and providing clear information tools
building energy codes standards and
labeling for appliances and Equipment as
well as buildings are among the most
effective instruments at our disposal
if then first well and together with
other supporting mechanisms
Energy Efficiency in buildings also
depends on us as consumers the choices
we make buildings we decide to live in
appliances and devices we buy and the
way we use them at home or our
workplaces
so what is the result of improving
Energy Efficiency significant Energy
savings reduced CO2 emissions lower
energy bills and improved comfort
ivity and health of people living in
them
the second thing we need is a massive
shift towards electricity
and of course I mean clean decarbonized
electricity produced from solar wind and
other low carbon sources
if we look at Europe for instance
more than 40 percent of household
households rely on natural gas for space
Heating and cool cooking
to complicate matters forty percent of
all gas consumed in Europe last year was
imported from Russia
so there is a climate imperative but
also a strong geopolitical and energy
security imperative to electrifying to
anticarbonize our buildings and make
them as efficient as possible
this doesn't only mean replacing energy
Supply from a gas pipeline with energy
Supply from an electric line
and here I reach back to my opening
point
we need to look at buildings differently
not only as gray concrete boxes as I
used to do but as potential potential
active players in the Energy System
so how can we make buildings active
through installing efficient and low
carbon Technologies such as solar panels
heat pumps energy storage making use of
smart and digital tools all Technologies
we already have
and in many cases their costs are
decreasing
let me introduce a word we don't often
hear
prosumer
think of a building not only as a
consumer of energy but as Pros humor
both consuming and producing
most of buildings can produce at least
part of the energy they need in many
cases they can produce more such
buildings already exist in many parts of
the world it's in Switzerland for
example there is even a single family
house that produces 800 percent of the
energy it needs
but still we have a long way to go to
make them a common practice
besides challenges with improving Energy
Efficiency and installing low carbon
Technologies another obstacle is that
our electricity networks or reads as we
call them
were designed to operate with large
centralized sources of generation like
power plants
and their design hasn't changed much
over the past Century
so increasing
decentralized or distributed
smaller scale generation especially from
variable renewable sources like solar
and wind can really put pressure on
existing electricity grids and challenge
their stability
so we also need to rethink the way our
entire electricity system is designed
smart grids can communicate to a
building through software algorithms and
smart controls and for example send a
signal to a connected device such as
your heating system to temporarily stop
or reduce energy use or if possible
shift it to the time when electricity is
more available cleaner or cheaper
this can really improve robustness of
the electricity Network and
help to avoid for example rolling
blackouts which are becoming more common
while consumers can get paid for it
if you have an electric car and you keep
it plugged in for a prolonged period of
time a smart charger can help to find
the best time to charge it depending on
the information from the grid
this can help save you money and support
the electricity system
it gets even more interesting electric
cars are essentially batteries on Wheels
so they can also be used as energy
storage and dispatch electricity to the
home or to the Grid at the time of need
a building itself can be used to store
energy for some time but you need to
make it energy efficient first
potentially you can also get paid for
making your energy storage available
for electricity system to store
renewable electricity when there is too
much of it for example when there is a
lot of sunshine or wind but demand is
not high enough to use it all
it's almost like renting your spare
bedroom on Airbnb just for hosting
electricity
now imagine a future with many many
buildings solar panels electric cars
energy storage other distributed devices
drawing electricity from the grid and
supplying electricity back to it
obviously we would need a way to manage
all this data efficiently and in real
time
make sure that devices interact well
with each other and able to communicate
to the grid
and optimize electricity demand and
supply for the entire system
virtual power plants digital and
intelligent platforms can do just that
they can aggregate electricity
consumption and production from many
distributed resources make use of local
storage
and manage complex interactions virtual
power plants can also facilitate
peer-to-peer renewable electricity
trading imagine that electricity that
you're building produce for example from
solar panel but you don't need at the
moment you can sell directly to another
building that needs it via an online
platform
a project like this has been running
already for several years in one of the
districts in Bangkok and is showing
benefits to the consumers the grid and
the planet
there are other pilot projects like this
in different countries but for them to
scale our policy Frameworks and
electricity Market design need to
undergo substantial changes
our buildings need to become more
efficient and grids need to evolve into
smarter managers of distributed energy
resources
it's a dramatic shift
it's like going from all television
world with a single broadcaster between
you connected world where everyone can
generate and share their own content
remember that building I grew up in
you might be surprised but during winter
it would often get too hot inside the
apartment even if it was -30 outside
it was because of Highly inefficient
central heating system
which we couldn't control or do anything
about
so we did this yes we had to open the
windows to get some fresh air and more
comfort
now I want to take you to my current
flat in Paris
where I have tiny but very smart boxes
attached to my electric heaters which
can automatically turn them on and off
maintaining comfortable temperatures
lowering my energy bills and providing
flexibility to the grid and I can
control all that on my smartphone
the technologies that we have now we
need the policies the Investments the
will
and the new way to look at buildings not
as passive users of energy but as active
players in the Energy System
buildings that can consume and produce
energy efficiently interact with the
smart grid and respond to its signals
providing flexibility and bringing us
closer to our climate targets thank you
[Applause]